hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the nightmare of my
life okay we got one more surgery to do
before we get to the super-secret alien
one that no one knows about yet because
I haven't done it but I've been trying
to well I gotta go into space again do a
brain surgery hopefully this one will be
less of a son of a [ __ ] and will
cooperate with me Father come on play
with me Bob
let me just caress your skull for a
little bit huh I love the shape of your
skull it's so round and so sand sure let
me just poke you in the eyeball here
yeah okay enough digging around what did
I use in order to get better at the get
to the skull this axe seems to be in a
good position so let's go ahead and use
that oh really you would turn around as
I grabbed you what okay alright is way
too early for me to be getting
frustrated
so this axe is totally useless oh really
really that's what I wanted to do come
on come on stop being such a [ __ ] about
and really pound that skull man pound
that brain get it really this is what
you choose to do whop nope nope hang on
wait no I almost got this he died I
started this ball murder in a minute
murder in a minute would be a good band
name god damn it I keep coming up with
great band names ah I don't need to come
up with band names I need to come up
with a band saw ha ha ha funny jokes why
is this sauna going what Wow Wow okay
look a lick oh we're gonna grab again
there we go now we got it on
it very gently do not saw the brain now
this this surgery is actually easier
than the other ones in my opinion oh oh
I know I don't think I can handle
another loss I don't think I can handle
another day of stress fullness stressed
I need some yoga in my life and some
chamomile tea little blaming another who
hopped up on caffeine I'm tired
big live stream yesterday still don't
know the total of that t-shirt sold I
will tell you guys this news I know but
for now I think we got it ok I could be
good what what I don't even want to know
because that's actually kind of good for
me no oh my god oh I wish I had my tool
where's my pool whatever I don't have my
tool here
oh that little music I was that the same
music that was playing before that I
didn't really notice because I was
raging uncontrollably hey whatever oh
man oh man oh look at it look at it
majestically floating away
it's beautiful in a way the brain the
symbolism of all that make us human
contain into one fatty globular sac and
there it goes swimming in drugs floating
in mid-air that pretty much sums up the
entire human existence doesn't up all
right now is good this come on daddy
it's gonna be easy got it all right now
if I recall wait a minute I may not have
even needed to do that why did I get a
lower score on the brain surgery than I
did on the kit never mind you know what
I don't care because what I need to do
is I need to input a certain code and it
is you Oh God oh okay hang on I gotta go
find what it is
wait a minute that's not right that was
supposed to be it ah that was okay I was
wrong so it's two nine six one four five
so two
Wow dad what did I did
Oh baby what lights are flashing hello
oh I don't think you do that whoops
well another way that I've killed
everyone around me whoosh oh my
doctoring anyways finally come to an end
I realized the horror what wait what oh
ha ha ha
hang on I got this I can't even grab the
tape I don't deserve to do this surgery
grab it you rabbit
gear rabbit there we go okay good enough
whatever I don't think I can get this
into the VCR perfect you're cooperating
with me you're cooperating with me yay
oh my goodness I'm so happy
ok get it yeah things are going so well
or nine or eight four nine four eight oh
we got it I like it to do it oh oh keep
it for nine or perform åberg burgers
bollocks transplant what what what what
is the burgers Ballack's killed me blorb
I'm gonna call you blorb um blorb which
one of these is the burgers Blaylock's
excuse me as you caressed oh yeah you
know what I like
come here let me ask you something oh so
essentially I Steve bite on my finger
which one is your burgers bollocks do
you realize that I was the greatest
doctor in the entire universe and you
picked me for this
very important operation so tell me
which one of these is your burgers
bollocks just tell me if I'm getting
warmer warmer
oh there I'm gonna go with this one this
one's a burgers bollocks I really don't
know what stop moving your hands it's
very creepy
get your hands out of there sorry stop
it
oh whoa buddy whoa hey you listen to me
I'm not a perform surgery on you I don't
care what you say in return I'm gonna do
it so let's get to it
uh uh I don't think this tool is ready
for this what what this doesn't even do
anything oh look at him he's in such
pain oh it's okay I'm a doctor
shut up alien nurse I'm a doctor what's
best I have no idea what I'm doing
in any way so just everyone shut up
there's not even my physique here he
didn't take a beating I mean I'm
splicing right into him and he's not it
doesn't seem to be uh got caught on my
metallically strong fingers let me just
drop that because I don't think that's I
don't think that's any good for this
where's my anti bloody bleedy oh maybe
you wouldn't he wouldn't respond well to
the drugs wait am i somehow still in
zero gravity and how are the tools
laying down on the ground I don't know
enough questions for now we'll see about
this one
okay no you're immune
what is that a hand inside your body
what is that oh my god what is the oh
okay I'm gonna guess that the burger
splurts
is the one in this cage down here with
that's like encased in this bony
structure what is this oh my god okay
I think it's oh wait no I see this like
a connecting yep
that's about right it's like a
connecting tube
come on get out the connecting boob whoo
yeah Oh what did I get it I think I got
it whoop good eye they're good I don't
need you anymore get these burgers
bollocks out of here this might not be
the burger sports I don't know what the
burgers flux is ah it's not done
where was the tool there is matul ah my
Google pulls finally sitting resting on
the table there so I just I just slice
you up a bit it cut it cut no don't get
cut that bad okay it's out well he's
gonna die
oh he's gonna die tablet dabble it to
hell he's gonna die well there really
wants nothing to do hey at least look at
this side you're my first alien kill I
mean you're the first person that could
not be saved by even the greatest doctor
in space so you should be honored and
look at the look of happiness on his
face he totally understands that his
sacrifice was worthy of whatever the
hell I was trying to do I don't even
know all right
far nine four no no that's at seven stop
[ __ ] yo damn it okay four nine four and
then the eight yeah okay we're gonna get
any higher blorb listen to me Laura
you're important to me you're very very
important to me I need to replace your
Gege blue by pewds ball oh I get it so
that was like burger pal has the that I
believe burger pal must have been that
so oh he's like honorary names for
youtubers that have done this I'm pretty
sure I'm not in here so let's just get
to it if there's if there was a pewds
ball I would imagine that this might be
it doink doink doink so I'm gonna try to
replace your pewds ball yeah you see
that good okay
all right let's give this a try now this
tool is quite effective it actually
caused some significant internal damage
without sacrificing in congruence surely
did you get you get you get to get to
get to getting it good you good you good
job come on robbery with me blorb god
damnit ah from mothers God Jesus all
right fine whatever that pool is not
apparently and good she's gonna keep
spinning over there this is laser even
work laser all it does what's blue slice
East I see honey Cuddy Cuddy often cut
cut bone and bone it actually does cut
bone did not know it but it seems wait
maybe if I stuff these pills in his
mouth he'll stop bleeding maybe that's
it oh my god that's such a great idea
oh my god I'm gonna try that hang on but
I gotta cut this it won't cut it's not
gonna cut it's not gonna cut it
ah jokes all right hang on wait a minute
I'm slightly cracking the bones but it's
not working it's not working
appropriately he's not flights in the
it's not slicing anything off he's
slicing things in and it's hurting him
but hang on let me try this I want to
give this a try
hang on pick up one of these no not that
let's gently pick up one of these peels
here no come back here bill
yeah I don't need you anyway got this
pill no I got this pill no I got this
pill
[ __ ] you I got damn it I didn't leave
their watch anyway I got this I got this
oh I got it I got okay there was a
stupid idea anyway I need never replace
his pills ball but apparently is gonna
die because again what is he what is
this what what it what Wow awesome
no this is kind of not awesome
what is it doing what what is this this
is not this is not a surgery tool this
is some sexual aid that I don't want to
know
alien sexual devices look at the laser
slow motion boy wink wink hilarious
that's actually hilarious badonk badonk
badonk badonk no okay enough of that
all right you alien bastard you think
you can escape from me the greatest
doctor in the universe I'm gonna give
this one more try
and then I'm gonna give it another try
later but for now I'm gonna get it
so what's magical device do I need to
replace now but I'll write the role or
as Oh robot god damn he is awesome oh if
anyone hasn't watched robot he's friggin
amazing so let me try this super ribs to
masher hear of spain's blink blink blink
blink see does it work
there's awake poink poink well it sure
is killin em real quick but it ain't
doing much really that's all you got
why is impacting the ribs with brute one
force trauma is so destructive to his
entire being this is not fair I don't
even know what the robots blorgon Wyman
is but I don't even know what it said
what name
let me just pound you in your face a bit
uh you like that you like that where's
your alien erogenous zones right in your
mouth oh oh this seems so wrong but it
feels so right
Lloyd blorp
orb blorb doctor are you sure that you
should be blowing that is it knock knock
knock knock knock
Lord Lord Eddie's dead how did that kill
you how oh look at who blinky blinky is
so funny and so wrong okay whatever
[ __ ] all these stupid alien devices I'm
sticking with what I know and what I
know is brutal murder no I mean saving
places they're gonna fly it out they
didn't trade me this in Nigeria aqua not
Nigeria Alcuin North America what I know
is the saw [ __ ] I can't even what what
really I what can you explain this to me
we're all just gonna stare at this for a
little bit because look at the
magnificence of what the hell that I
managed to do okay
take number 89 however many times I've
been doing this we're gonna try this
again okay you're ready you're ready ass
son of a [ __ ] what a magical the pewds
ball
I know it's ass gonna be that's gonna be
less let me just open it up so I know
exactly how do i oh I may have not how
do i how do I open you uh-oh oh that's
not gonna be good at least a guy made my
radio for my other surgery so that they
know what keeps me calm in this crazy
world that you have constructed for me I
know that the saw does not actually do
much damage if you just very light about
it though it's the perfect for removing
the bones because it's bone saw and
technically it's probably what's used in
normal surgery probably I mean I know
this because I was taught how to be a
normal sergeant back in Nigeria acqua
not 90 I've turned into Christopher
Walken with
reason Wow Z's dead jury on an alien
whatwhat's the deal oh forget it
I don't even know anymore but this
seemed to have worked it seemed to have
work so I just need to get the pewds
ball a little bit open I know what you
are I know what you are but don't be
don't be loose don't be a douche I'm a
doctor come on you got oh that's more
like it
ha ha ha that is more like it
the pewds ball is glowing bright right
in the night so I can't get it back I'm
gonna have to try something else send
that off on its merry way
not the way I wanted to send it okay
whatever let me just hold your hand for
a bit use me Laura but I know this is a
tender moment between us
but we can't let this operation get in
the way of our love way your fingers
twitch like that sends me wild and with
this calm down here for a second here
calm down our radio has gone crazy okay
listen to me we're gonna be okay you're
gonna be okay get out of here
strains internal hand you what that what
what is this this is a hand that is a
hand you can't pull me that that is a
hand okay so the pewds ball is almost
entirely exposed it actually is entirely
exposed it's awesome that's actually
kind of Awesome
I can't rip it out yeah because I need
to get to it my tool my tool is here
poor I've never used it before this but
I love it
oh my god
I've never used it before space it's
always been there but I just never used
it I don't know why really good at
cutting so I thought apparently not okay
there we go
get that intestine out of there so that
I can get to the way the thing you don't
bleed too much don't bleed too much what
I don't care
get out of there my virus antivirus it's
updated like hey tell you loose and I'm
like [ __ ] you goddamn it let me just get
to D let me get to the thing oh god damn
it don't stop it stop being a dick oh
don't do that
Jesus Christ just cooperate with me cut
it cut the [ __ ]
god damnit you got to be joking me this
is going perfectly fine up until what
know what you're draggin I'm not doing
it I swear to god I'm not doing this
they're finally he's gonna die Jesus
well know what fine whatever [ __ ] get
out of here
get out of here get out of here I don't
have a lot of time I'm on a time crunch
now give me the ball give me the ball
give me the ball
oh you gotta be kidding me that little
bit of bone is still encasing it in
there whatever I'm gonna try this what's
before just need to get a little bit yes
need to get a little bit yeah I stole it
no no no no no no stop it oh my god he's
gonna die he's gonna die oh my god I'm
so close okay know what's cutting in I
just got to get this little bit of own
he's gotta get this little bit a little
bit of alien bone oh come on don't kill
him there we go stop stop stop
tell me it's not out nope nope nope oh
there's a bottom connection no oh Laser
laser gonna have to do laser give me
laser no don't kill him he basically
killed him basic god damnit just slice
place it off
yeah boot bombs out I mean wait hang on
let me can i free this with this right
right oh no no no race against time race
against time open up the fuse ball
replace it Oh God Oh give me give me
give me
Oh release the beads ball release it
Oh God there we go get it grab it put
the other one out another one it's
already gone
oh I did it I did it I fellas can't
believe I did it
I can't believe it oh that was down to
the wire
ninety-eight blood left Wow
I don't think I could have gotten that
any closer if I tried seriously that was
that was something else how my I think
I've heard my neighbors pounding on the
walls but they shouldn't because it's
noon
goddamn oh I did it I did it I replaced
one of them there's still other things
to replace I might go back and replace
it but I got that pewds ball in there
even though I see it floating up by the
screen over there don't worry about that
that don't matter that don't matter at
all because I got it I got it I got it I
got it
yeah all right so anyway if you want to
see me do the other ones let me know in
the comments below or look at a look at
this thing goo
I got a little have to say so anyway
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
no nothing
No
all right